health workers face a huge challenge
trying to contain this season's flu
outbreak it is the most widespread in
recent years with at least 37 child
deaths reported so far the biggest
clusters are in the South and West dr.
Anthony Fauci is director of the
National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases he's part of the
effort to fight future outbreaks he
joins us from the headquarters of the
National Institutes of Health in
Bethesda Maryland
dr. pouchy good morning always good to
see you good morning first let me ask
you this why is this year's virus so
deadly well there are a couple of
reasons the type of virus that's
dominating this year is what we call an
h3n2 the designation of this particular
kind of influenza it historically is a
bad actor so whenever you have this
virus this type of virus dominating you
generally see a bad season and you
generally have more complications
particularly among the vulnerable people
in whom complications are more common
such as the elderly such as individuals
with underlying conditions as well as
children from birth to four years old
and also as we know the vaccine this
year although it's always best to get
vaccinated is not the perfect vaccine it
is not as we would say favourably
efficacious in the sense that we only
don't know right now what the
efficaciousness is going to be but it
likely is not going to be much more than
around 30% I say that with some
trepidation because I don't want people
not to get vaccinated every type of an
of protection against against the virus
with a vaccine is better than no
protection at all so a combination of a
vaccine that doesn't work very well in a
really bad virus so given that
combination dr. Fauci what should people
do well the first thing you should do
and again getting back to vaccination if
you have not been vaccinated you should
get vaccinated that's for sure then if
in fact you do get infected if you have
what looks like it's going to be a
serious infection don't
to get to a health care provider who can
get you an anti influenza antiviral like
Tamiflu this is particularly true for
people who fall into the risk categories
where complications are common so if
you're an elderly person or you have an
underlying disease you should not wait
to get anti flu medication you know one
of the interesting things in reading
about everything that you write about
doctor Falchi is it's been a hundred
years since that that lethal 1918 flu
and you're saying there could be one
virus that could be catastrophic why
can't we get a universal vaccine to
protect us well influenza is a very
unusual virus in that it tends to drift
from year to year and sometimes when you
get a pandemic it's what we call a shift
there's a major change this is so
different from other important viruses
like measles the measles I got as a
child is the same measles that's in the
vaccine that we vaccinated my children
with so you don't have to worry about
that change
so what we're fighting against this
trying to get a vaccine that would
induce a response against that part of
the virus that doesn't change from
season to season or with a pandemic we
refer to that as a universal flu vaccine
and only relatively recently have we
been able to get an insight to
understand what part of that virus
actually doesn't change very much from
year to year and now how can we induce
with a vaccine a response that would be
dominant against that particular part of
the virus because the vaccines we make
now when they protect you they make a
response that's a good response but it
happens to be against that part of the
virus that tends to drift because of
mutations from year to year okay dr.
Fuji thanks so much for being with us